and as we just heard trump's acquittal
doesn't mean his legal troubles are over
there are multiple investigations into
his conduct
at both the state and federal level
which could scupper his hopes for a
political comeback
we have this look now at some of the
legal battles
awaiting the former president
the president's niece mary trump not
only wrote a book about her uncle
she accuses him and two of his siblings
of cheating her out of her inheritance
fraud was not just the family business
begins her claim against him
it was a way of life the doctor of
psychology is seeking half a million
dollars in damages
michael cohen trump's former lawyer did
business on behalf of trump
and for that he was sentenced to three
years in jail
and he is a cheat cohen paid playboy
model karen mcdougall
and adult entertainer stormy daniels to
keep quiet during the 2016 election
about their sexual relationships to
trump
as sitting president trump was not
charged for violating campaign
funding rules but he could be now
for more than a year new york district
attorney cyrus vance
requested access to tax and financial
documents
pertaining to trump and his businesses
on suspicion of insurance and bank fraud
and tax evasion
it's unclear if trump's tax returns will
show evidence of crimes
but should suspicions harden trump could
face severe consequences
it's totally fake news made up fake
trump is said to have artificially
inflated the value of his real estate
portfolio when applying for credit
and undervalued it significantly when
paying property tax
trump's son eric is the executive vice
president of the trump organization
he has already given witness testimony
[Music]
no man is above the law including the
president united states
several women have accused trump of
sexual misconduct including rape
he has consistently called the claims
fabrications
in the face of such denials some of
trump's accusers have launched libel
actions
among them summer zervos an
ex-contestant on trump's tv show the
apprentice
and gene carroll a former columnist for
elle magazine
i just want to find
11 780
votes and then there's the phone call on
january 2nd
after votes were cast in georgia in
which trump apparently pressured an
electoral official
that too could have legal consequences
you